let's talk about the seven surprising
things that you can do
to speed up your ability to burn
fat now there are things that you know
and there's things that you may not know
that you need to know so this video is
about giving you all the knowledge so
you can really overcome the barrier of
not being able to not just achieve your
weight loss but to
get into and stay into fat burning it's
surprising to me how many people
can't seem to get into fat burning or
even stay there long enough to see a
really good change and might as well
tell you some things to do to speed it
up that you may have never heard before
okay so now what are we talking about
we're talking about
transitioning from where you're at to an
ideal situation most people are at a
situation where they're just running on
blood sugars okay they're just running
on their stored sugar in their liver and
up and down up and down with energy and
they're not tapping into the fat which
that's where all the reserve of energy
is i mean an average thin person has
over a hundred thousand calories of
stored fat in their body and if you were
able to tap into that all the time uh
boy your energy would be very very nice
and consistent so we're going to talk
about how to be fat adapted and we're
not just talking about
three days of getting your body to start
to burn ketones okay that's different
than being in full fat adaptation
and unfortunately it does take some more
time
it takes anywhere between one to three
months to fully get there but i'm going
to give you some important things to
speed it up that actually might be very
surprising to you but before we begin i
think it's important to understand how
do we know
we are fat adapted okay so there are
several factors that you need to look at
number one you're able to go longer
without eating you're not getting so
hungry anymore your appetite is
disappearing okay that's number one
number two you no longer have cravings
to carbs which is going to make it very
easy to stick to the program if you
don't have cravings i mean if you have
cravings uh i don't know how anyone can
stick to any any plan um it's their
their life's gonna be miserable uh and
the temptation is gonna throw them off
and the third factor is i already
mentioned this energy your energy is not
gonna come up and down up and down it's
going to be very very stable and
consistent and you're going to have more
energy why because
you're burning fat calories and a fat
calorie has more than double
the amount of energy than
protein or
carbohydrates so when you tap into fat
you're actually releasing more energy in
your body is more efficient what you
have to realize is your body was
designed to burn fat
not rely on glucose 24 7 despite what
certain people tell you about the brain
needs glucose etc any glucose that your
body needs can be easily produced
by your body it's called gluconeogenesis
and that word gluconeogenesis means the
new creation of glucose from from other
sources like protein like fat
like ketones so this glucose that your
brain runs on which is only a portion of
it by the way doesn't have to come from
consuming glucose all right number four
you're going to have enhanced
mental activity in other words you're
going to be more focused you're going to
be more concentrated you're going to be
more creative you're going to be able to
get more stuff done i mean even your
ability to learn will be enhanced and
number four is all about cognitive
function but i should add an additional
part of that which is your mood is going
to be elevated being fat adapted
actually brings you up you're less
depressed less anxiety and you're
genuinely feeling much much better mood
wise all right number five
you're gonna have more endurance when
you exercise
your ability to
generate energy and
maintain a certain level of exercise is
going to be enhanced when you are fat
adapted if you're not fat adapted and
you exercise guess what you're going to
run out of glucose really fast because
we don't store a lot of glucose and so
when certain people exercise and they
hit this wall
they start to get fatigued that's
because they're running out of glucose
but if you've adapted to fat burning
you can go longer all right number six
your sleep actually will be enhanced in
fact the need for sleep does go down not
a lot but you'll find that you'll need a
little less sleep all right
that's how we know we're in fat
adaptation there's a lot of different
variables that affect your metabolism
your ability to burn fat but what i want
to know right now and please put this in
the comments section
is which one of the 15 factors do you
feel that is the hardest to change which
one of these factors do you feel that
you can't do anything about
that's what i want to know so let's go
through the list number one genetics
okay your genes
number two
your age
all right number three your environment
number four
your food your diet number five your
hormones
number six your muscles your muscle mass
number seven exercise number eight your
stress level number nine your nutrition
and number ten your sleep eleven the
timing of when you eat and not eat
twelve the drugs or medication that you
are on thirteen the chemicals and the
food that you eat fourteen your
metabolic rate and 15 your health
reserve how much extra health or
capacity of health you have now out of
all of these 15 factors
which one do you feel
is the most difficult for you to control
all right now that you put that in the
comments section
that is the area that you need to focus
on and guess what you have the ability
to affect every single one of these
items and whichever one you can affect
is your weakness but some people will
say well i can't affect my genes
well have you ever heard about something
called epigenetics which is above your
genetics
those are all the things environmentally
that you can control these involve
stress level things that you can do to
put yourself in better environments
epigenetics could involve your state of
mind just changing your attitude about
certain things it could be about
changing your stress level it's
definitely about changing your diet and
so all these factors can greatly help
you control
your genes
and leverage your genes
towards improving your survival now what
about your age can you do anything about
that well yes there are things you can
do there are things you can eat that can
help extend your life and decrease the
risk of dying and look more youthful and
be more youthful on the inside versus
all the other things that can accelerate
the aging process
and then you have some people that just
cannot change their environment too well
and so they're stuck between a rock and
a hard place but the more you can
control these factors the more that
you're going to be able to control your
ability to not just burn fat but control
your metabolism your quality of life and
your level of health so let's run on the
list of things that will help you get
into fat burning okay more on a
consistent basis so number one exercise
okay
now
you may already know that
high intensity interval training is the
best exercise for fat burning
stimulating growth hormone
and you may already know that sprinting
is one of the best high intensity
interval training type exercises but of
course for most people
if they have arthritis if they're
getting older
they probably shouldn't be sprinting too
much so they would have to do some other
type of exercise that involves the
concept of high intensity short duration
but what's more important to know
is that the benefit of that is not doing
the exercise in fact during the exercise
you're stressing your body out the
benefit is when you stop when you
recover okay
and so when i was in practice i ran into
so many people who over trained
and they didn't realize that even for
some people if they're older three times
a week is over training i'll give you an
example
one gentleman came in and he was
exercising three days a week and not
burning any fat at all
i lowered it to one day a week
that's when he started to finally burn
fat
another lady
tried to work out every day at the gym
over a course of a year
and i think she lost like one maybe two
pounds at the very most
okay and all we did
was help her sleep reduce exercise i
think it was it twice a week
and that's when she started to burn fat
so what you might want to try is
exercising less keep the exercise
intensity up and really have a good
workout but only do it once or twice a
week that can make a huge difference
the results are during the recovery but
the recovery is very important all right
number two um taking some apple cider
vinegar before bed in a little bit of
water so let's say you took a i don't
know four to six ounces of water
you can do it like an hour before bed
and a tablespoon of apple cider vinegar
now why would that help you lose weight
because
acetic acid in the apple cider vinegar
is very beneficial to decreasing your
liver's ability to make sugar okay so it
slows down something called
glyconeogenesis it helps lower your
blood sugars and at the heart of fat
burning it's all about fixing insulin
resistance and applied vinegar can
greatly help you i've had many people
just add this small little tip to their
daily lifestyle and they started to burn
fat so you might want to try that all
right number three
we all know that sleep is very very
important in fact a lot of the fat
burning occurs when you're sleeping and
you may have already seen one of my
videos when i recommend taking vitamin
d3 10 000 iu's with the k2
and
b1 or nutritional yeast before bed
because the vitamin d helps reset the
circadian waves
and vitamin b1 helps the excessive
thinking all the time and you do that
with the nutritional yeast but if you
took that before bed
it would enhance your sleep and you may
have seen my other video
on a breathing technique of slowing your
breath down especially when you're
trying to sleep
and
even in general for stress reduction
breathing through your nose slowing the
breath in can help you fall asleep
pretty fast it can also
pull you out of a panic attack it can
also help with anxiety and reduce
cortisol but there's another little tip
i want to share with you about
sleeping that can help you the goal is
to get a little bit more sleep if you're
trying to burn more fat and so you can
try to get an extra half hour or an hour
of sleep
but if you have the ability to take a
nap during the day and you can do that
that can greatly increase your ability
to burn fat so even if it's a half hour
go ahead and try that and you might be
very surprised that that is the thing
that can greatly speed things up for you
your sleep doesn't necessarily always
have to be together at one time frame
sometimes you if you don't sleep at
night definitely take a nap all right
number four stress really really
important topic because stress increases
cortisol cortisol increases insulin
and insulin will stop you from losing
weight so you may already know that long
walks in nature are very very beneficial
because it gets you out of your head and
you just get space and your stress level
goes down and you may already know that
nutritional yeast has b1 and that can
help especially nervous tension and
anxiety and that can also lower stress
and you may also know if you've seen my
other videos that being outside getting
exposure to sun
or
not even the peak sun but the sunrise or
the sunset or even being in front of a
fireplace or a campfire gives you a type
of light called infrared which increases
melatonin even during the day which is a
very powerful antioxidant
which will then also help you sleep at
night
it can also help lower your stress and
you may have seen that video if you
haven't got to check that one out but
that's not the tip the tip
is this
doing physical work
around the house around your yard well
especially around the yard
is way more important than doing
exercise
for lowering stress
so if you have the opportunity to choose
between the two physical exercise or
physical work
physical work hands down is better
because of what it can do
to kind of pull you out of
this constant
problem solving that you have physical
work is a great activity for shifting
your attention
off the problems of life and
onto something else like some physical
work that you're doing whether it's
fixing something repairing something
cleaning something any of those items
will help you all right number five
staying very very consistent with your
low carbs okay
um
every week i do a live show and
inevitably um people that have great
success
um sometimes stall
and a lot of times it boils down to this
one thing they don't realize that just a
little bit of carb or going off the
program too frequently even if it's a
little bit of something
can be devastating to the results
a really good test called a1c
could be done
and the reason i like that test is not
necessarily to see your risk factors for
diabetes
it just shows you an average of three
months of blood sugars because
you can check your blood sugars today
and then tonight have a little carb and
your blood sugars can be off and then
check it in two days and your blood
sugars can show a good marker but a1c
will really reveal if you've been
cheating or not being consistent because
it checks the average of three months
including all those cheap days so being
very consistent
and not giving in
to even a little bit of carbs can
greatly help you and if you are giving
in too frequently that could be the
reason why you're not burning fat all
right number six this relates to uh
intermittent fasting okay
this tip
um can help you um in the beginning of
fasting
i always recommend you consume more fat
especially at the end of the meal
now are you going to lose more weight no
because you're eating a lot of fat and
your body is going to have to metabolize
that
and burn that for energy
and burn less of your own fat reserve
but the purpose of eating fat in the
beginning of this program
is to help you fast longer to go longer
without eating
because that's when a lot of the magic
happens not just
with the reduction of calories not just
with all the other benefits of cognitive
function and losing weight but with the
benefit
of correcting
the underlying root
problem that you have
which is insulin resistance so the
longer we fast
the less stimulation of insulin that we
have
so the better the
receptors for insulin can be upgraded
and work better
and be more receptive and the faster
we're going to get into fat adaptation
and the faster we can improve our
metabolism so in the beginning of this
program you add more fat
but as you start becoming more fat
adapted and you have these improved
indicators like your you can go longer
without eating you have no more cravings
more energy etc then
you start to decrease your fat now i'm
not talking about going on a low fat
diet
i'm talking about not adding additional
fat i'm talking about not adding the mct
oil not adding the big handful of nuts
after the meal
talking about not adding the keto
desserts like the big fat bombs because
what that's gonna do
it's going to force your body
to burn more of your fat reserve which
it's already doing and it's going to be
easier because your body is already
adapted so in the beginning of the
program do more fat
and towards the middle of the program
when your fat adapted one to three
months then reduce your fat and then
when you hit your goal weight you can
add more fat in there to maintain your
weight but i never want you to go low
fat and i definitely never want you to
go below 75 grams of fat per day all
right and number seven
this is interesting i've noticed in
america at least when people
go to europe
and they don't reduce their calories
they eat more a lot of times i lose
weight
why is that because in certain countries
in europe especially there's there's
more nutrient dense foods than america
okay and so
nutrient dense foods
can help improve your health and
actually help you lose weight i know a
lot of europeans that come to america
that are not necessarily eating more
calories but they're gaining more weight
in fact their bodies sometimes become
destroyed so
welcome to america the land of the
opposite of nutrient-dense foods we have
foods that are void of nutrition so when
some people recommend you can do dirty
keto i mean it doesn't matter the
quality just make sure you have those
macros just realize that that's not the
best advice
so consuming the healthy version of the
ketogenic diet and the definition of
that is adding the quality
the nutrient-dense foods to your plan i
think would be some good advice all
right so now that you have this
additional information please in the
comment section
make note so i can read this
of what areas that you need to focus on
that you can see that this potentially
could work for you and i think a really
important video if you have not seen it
yet is this one on
melatonin check it out right now
you